30,1 degrés c'est notre chiffre de jour
la température constatée à Dax dans les
Landes et Orthez dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques record absolu dans
ces deux villes au mois de mars n'est
que la troisième fois de l'histoire de
la météo en France qu'on enregistre des
chiffres supérieurs à 30 degrés en mars
record battu aussi à Mont-de-Marsan 29,9
degrés à Clara qu'en Haute-Garonne
Villefranche-de-Rouergue dans l'Aveyron
ou encore Belves en Dordogne en cause
des vents chauds venus du sud mais aussi
un effet de fun quand de l'air à 15
degrés frais et humide vient se heurter
à une chaîne de montagne cela génère des
précipitations l'air qui redescend
ensuite du relief est chaud et sec il
peut atteindre 25 degrés un phénomène
accentué par le réchauffement climatique
à part ça Mathias Giraud met le feu à la
neige et saute à la bougie
ou presque
voici le premier peste jump de nuit de
l'histoire 20 minutes après le coucher
du soleil depuis l'Aiguille croche de
Megève 2487 mètres fait haute rousse
pour vol de nuit dans l'air alpin ça
c'est pas rien
depuis quelques années les trottinettes
électriques sont partout et notamment à
Paris ou près de 15000 sont en
libre-service et tandis que le ministre
des Transports souhaite durcir les
conditions d'utilisation et augmenter
les amendes en cas d'infraction et que
certains mettent en avant les nombreux
accidents qu'elles peuvent provoquer
la mère de Paris est depuis 2019 vent
debout contre ses engins si j'avais pu
les interdire je les aurai interdites
des yeux une bouche et voilà un tas de
poubelles transformé en œuvre de street
art des monstres comme les appels bisque
l'artiste parisien derrière ces
personnages qui ont envahi la capitale
avec ses bombes de peinture noir et
blanches il s'amuse et offre au passant
un regard différent sur les amas de
déchets une œuvre plus que jamais
éphémère à l'heure où les éboueurs de la
capitale reprennent le travail après 10
jours de grève
des paris en trottinette
c'est qu'on vit à Paris pour pouvoir
utiliser les trottinettes et gagner du
temps c'est super c'est silencieux c'est
logique ouais j'adore ça et alors je
vais le dire moi je roule pas en
trottinette j'aime être derrière c'est
vrai
je vous souhaite une bonne émission en
bonté le matin
complètement faux elle était générée par
un ordinateur non le pape François ne
porte pas un manteau de grand couturier
barracobama et Angela Merkel ne passent
pas leur retraite ensemble pourtant même
en les examinant il est parfois
difficile de détecter que ces images
sont fausses réalisées par un logiciel
autonome ces montages prouvent autant
les progrès que les dangers de
l'intelligence artificielle à tel point
que des centaines d'experts demandent
aujourd'hui d'interrompre son
développement pendant 6 mois bon
Télématin bonjour France this is Donald
trumpet
télémata great again l'intelligence
artificielle pourrait conduire à la
disparition de 300 millions d'emplois
selon une banque américaine dans des
entrepôts d'Ikea en Belgique ou en
Allemagne des drones réalisent déjà
l'inventaire des stocks 12 fois plus
vite que des humains
des supermarchés comme celui-ci d'Amazon
au Royaume-Uni se passe de caissiers des
caméras intelligentes restent en temps
réel la liste des achats des clients et
leur envoie la facture d'ici 10 ans et
bien on pourra lancer des modules
d'hibernation artificielle ça s'appelle
comme ça on pourra pas du tout envie de
me retrouver avec 3 mois de puces
pour les astronautes ça va être
extrêmement intéressant je vous
expliquer rapidement comment ça se
passera ce qu'ils imaginent c'est qu'on
mettra effectivement l'astronaute dans
une capsule souple qu'on fera baisser la
température en dessous des 10 degrés
qu'on mettra une petite lumière tamisée
et qu'on induira un état on appelle ça
de torpeur en fait ça se rapproche de
l'hibernation comme le connaissent les
ours ou les marmottes c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui
pour que pour qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
commencer en fait cette épreuve
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait là il fait la
vaisselle ou quoi vas-y
[Musique]
l'hibernation ça n'est pas le sommeil
c'est pas la même chose c'est un peu
comme si vous mettiez votre corps et
votre vie en pause c'est ça qui se passe
quand on est en hibernation c'est-à-dire
que votre rythme cardiaque va baisser à
quelques battements par minute votre
activité cérébrale alors non normalement
oui c'est vrai sauf que là encore une
fois c'est pas dans notre nature donc ce
qu'ils imagine c'est qu'on aura quand
même une petite nourriture par
intraveineuse
il est possible que ça existe pour de
vrai qu'on est une puce dans la tête si
on a un ajout d'ordinateur et qu'on peut
mettre une application ou un logiciel
quel logiciel vous choisissez moi je
pense que je choisis Google Maps pour ne
plus jamais me perdre dans la vie est-ce
qu'il y en a qui vous ferait kiffer
d'avoir genre juste en y pensant
des recettes les plus connues de la
cuisine italienne depuis quelques jours
les pâtes à la carbonara sont au coeur
d'une polémique elle serait en réalité
américaine
un non sens pour les Italiens
non ça non je peux dire ce que j'en
pense vraiment c'est n'importe quoi
la carbonara ne serait pas un plat
romain mais trouverait son origine à la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale quand
les soldats américains apportent du
bacon en Italie et on l'idée de
l'associer aux œufs et aux pattes bref
la carbo c'est américain ce sont aussi
les Américains qui auraient inventé la
fameuse pizza napolitaine elle serait
mais aux États-Unis dit-il et ensuite
dans les années 50
en réalité il y a tellement d'Italiens
qui sont partis en Amérique et que j'ai
envie de dire que toute la cuisine
italienne est en fait italo-américaine
et le fruit de toute cet échange il
s'agit d'une attaque surréaliste au
symbole de la cuisine italienne dit le
secrétaire d’état à l'agriculture on ne
touche pas à ce patrimoine on cherche à
discréditer notre pays dit-il faut dire
qu'en ce moment l'Italie essaie de faire
rentrer la gastronomie italienne au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO ah oui
c'est pas le bon moment évidemment c'est
de la mauvaise pub quand on démonte
information qu'on va qualifier d'asser
étonnante une boulette de viande de
mammouth a été mise au point par des
scientifiques une boulette géante même
cultivée en laboratoire à partir d'une
protéine vieille de milliers d'années le
met a été exposé sous une cloche de
verre pour que ça voulait vivre la vie
immense boulette il faut avoir faim on
va encore passer des tests de sécurité
avant d'être goûté on verra qui osera
qui osera goûter la fameuse boulette de
mammouth et si vous voulez bien vous
tourner Versailles pour saluer
l'hôtellerie spectateur voilà ce ne
faisons pas la guerre faisant l'amour